normal and thank you for coming in the
mini on this very hot day to the manager
without going to survive we will see to
begin with work welfare wednesdays live
damn leadership contest now and not many
of the general public will have been
watching as with you aware that they'll
have been getting on with their lives
people tend to do with politics and they
might begin to take an interest in the
final week final few weeks for those who
haven't been watching it what's your
elevator pitch what's your top line up
of what of what the point of your
candidacy is I suppose my argument is
that in very many respects this is a
liberal age particularly young people
who have liberal instincts attitudes
values open internationalist dynamic
believing in opportunity but for all and
yet predominantly those people who have
liberal values don't identify themselves
over the days so we've failed to connect
with them and our task as it were really
is to manage to reach out to those
people do you think the Liberal Democrat
election campaign had some pretty
positive paddy ashdown I was a great
liberal leader of the path ran that
campaign that have been rumors going
around that paddy wasn't listening some
of the criticisms of that campaign do
you think there were some problems with
your election campaign well I don't put
the blame on any individual certainly
not planning but I think that if i can
if i could think through the sort of
causes of the sort of perfect storm that
hit us in May first of all this was an
election driven by fear many people said
to be on the doorstep including in my
constituency of North Norfolk we love
having you as our MP we want to keep you
but we're really scared and that emotion
just sort of flood it through England
and it was very very powerful people I
thought that Miliband wasn't is toxic
Brown as we ran up the energy it proved
that he was more toxic actually but we
made our mistakes as well we we lost
trust which is critical to a political
party once you lose trust people stop
listening to you and I think we stop
talking about our purpose what our
mission was so we define ourselves in
relation to others but we said we will
cut less than the toys and borrow less
than labor it sort of felt like well
we're a little bit less bad than one and
a bit less bad than the other you could
almost say you an apologist for the
coalition Liberal Democrat row you know
obviously you you've been less critical
of the girl in the coalition at your
party play then Tim Farron has and would
you go into coalition with the
Conservatives or later again so look we
are a pluralist party I the one thing I
am NOT is a sort of tribal politician
like my purple are not rival never
Democrats no no I'm not I have very
strong liberal values but my purpose my
mission as a politician has to be to
make a difference between as lies and
you only do that by securing our
securing power to disburse power and to
apply different values so first of all I
will always defend our decision to go
into coalition that's not say we didn't
make big mistakes I've already said that
we did but to close off the idea of
coalition would be mantle
for a liberal party with the leads and
pluralist politics one things that the
position is Divya with Tim Farron is
about some of his views on abortion and
gay rights do you think someone with
traditional Catholic value Christian
values to leave the Liberal Democrats
this is absolutely not about the idea of
a Christian being a leader as the party
of course that should be the place and
it's the only issue is a debate about
liberal values and about and inevitably
your vote and you see a conflict there
between those teeth will inevitably both
of our voting records have been in
debate in this election some people
condemn me because I stepped up to the
plate in the coalition and if you are in
government you can't make it a judgment
to vote against certain things you take
it or leave it also on coalition what
was the biggest mistake you think that
lived and cats made within the last
government so losing trust over to
achieve things that you can debate the
whole sort of course of events that led
to that the signing of the pledge which
i think is a mistake to the point where
the decision was taken by those
negotiating the coalition deal 22 in
effect agree to the rising tuition fees
but that broke people's trust and and as
I said earlier once you do think I can
ever be recovered so yes of course it
can and people make mistakes in life and
when you make mistakes you have to face
up to it you have to apologize and
recognize the failure and critically
learn from them I think also if you look
at the power performance in coalition I
think we're achieving great things
particularly the people bring in cutting
tax people and they pay pensions reforms
in a very liberal direction my work on
mental health speak to our values and we
implemented for the first time of the
post-war period
liberal values in government but I
didn't think we were nearly clear enough
at the start that this was a sort of
business like professional relationship
we were acting in the national interest
but this was two very different parties
working in the machine turist but
negotiating for the things that both
parties believed it and I think we
weren't Kira and finally if you're not
successful in this leadership college
would you serve on Tim Ferriss team look
it up to Tim to make a judgment about
the outcome of this race but I won't
sink in any way to undermine Tim to
leadership we hate to you with an often
said would you do the Home Affairs we're
not going we're not going to operate in
that way I think it's with a party of
eight we have to be much more fluid much
more flexible than that but I will play
my part in the lib dems i'm not going to
walk away i will play my part so you
would take on a public law representing
the party if you laugh